what kind of setup is this only a true
legend
what are you talking about i mean
i'm not here to show anybody up but
thank you for
talking to me in your booth i feel
honored
well i mean you know this is i'm i'm
lucky that
uh that i have my my boot my workspace
in my home
oh you're lit yeah yes
will's life is pretty lit working from
home teaching his kids
oh and having a baby during a global
pandemic
what has been keeping you busy well
what's been keeping me busy uh you know
um
kids kids be keeping me very busy
um i have more kids now
i just i just had uh we just had a son
six weeks ago
uh yeah so it's been uh it's been a busy
time but you know the kids were doing uh
uh remote learning
for the first few months which was
difficult for everybody for them
for us um a lot of parents can relate to
that
a lot of kids can congratulations on the
new baby that's amazing
thank you you know i'm i'm imagining you
know what voice to use to make a child
go to sleep
sure i know how to i know how to you
know
drop it to the place that gets them to
sleep
that's the money yeah he does i will say
my youngest son denny
uh he uh when i talk to him kind of
really quietly when he's
resting on me like this he does tend to
pass out it's nice
and when will is not using his soothing
voice he's using that comedy genius to
executive produce the new quippy show
your daily horoscope
a daily animated series that brings to
life all your favorite astrology signs
i need a suitcase of rose and a roller
bag of thin mints
someone make a mimi out of my face did
anyone hear that
here can we go in the hallway i want to
say it again in front of people if i did
drive an
eco-friendly car it would be a tesla the
expensive one at the peasant one i know
that you're a taurus uh
what would you say your sign is known
for
[Music]
probably uh being stubborn i think that
that's kind of the hallmark when
somebody says
what's your sign and i say taurus they
generally go like
oh and i know that they're thinking oh
you're stubborn
i'm a gemini okay oh so you're a gemini
yeah what do you know about me i need
all the tea i think geminis
right don't they get that um they get
that kind of thing of being like
dual having kind of dual personality a
little bit is that what you
yeah i mean i'm not saying that that's
you
i'm just saying that that's kind of what
people think right
yeah no it's true it's true kind-hearted
organized closet and properly shelved
dishes
got it nothing like aries or anyone
aries hangs out with oh and can't be
allergic to cats
obviously are you a big believer in
daily horoscopes
you know i have to admit i did read
daily horoscopes often
um when i lived in new york for years
and i'd agreed the new york post on the
subway and i'd always read my
my horoscope i'd go like sports section
my horoscope and page six and that was
what i did
up next for will teaming up with his
good friends jason bateman and sean
hayes for their new podcast smartlist
we came up with this idea of doing that
every episode one of us brings a guest
that the other two don't know about so
it's a full surprise
oh i love that yeah so all of a sudden
we reveal who it is and the other two
are like oh man what
what's fun about that is it keeps it
very real very off the cuff we're not
prepared nobody has
preconceived notions of what they want
to ask other than the guy who brought
the guest